welcome to the us-mexico border a place
of sweltering summers and a sweltering
debate on immigration and national
security oh hey look there's already a
wall and fences and concrete barricades
and gunboats and drones and SUVs the
border is nearly two thousand miles long
it includes uninhabited desert major
cities and the Rio Grande River we
always hear about border security and
the u.s. spends billions every year on
our so-called protection but what's
really going on here many things cross
the border from monarch butterflies to
heroin to people looking for a better
life
ninety-three percent of the cocaine
consumed in the US comes in through this
border having made its way from South
America that along with marijuana and
methamphetamines are smuggled through
tunnels on lightweight planes in car
tires even shot over the border in
t-shirt cannons when the u.s. is the
largest market in the world for illegal
drugs there's always a way in then there
are guns which flow the other way every
year an average of two hundred and fifty
three thousand firearms bought in the
u.s. crossed into Mexico and the insane
amount of gun dealers on the US side
make that really easy there's three per
mile there are dozens of official entry
points along the border lines and
increased security mean it can take
hours to get from Cuates to El Paso a
distance of less than a mile though many
people cross every day for work school
or vacation we mostly hear about illegal
crossings it's hard to be exact about
how many cross most of what we know is
based on how many people the Border
Patrol apprehends and that number has
actually been decreasing but crossing
the border illegally means a lot more
than just waiting it means walking for
days on end under the Sun over some
rugged terrain
it means exhaustion and dehydration some
migrants hire what are called coyotes to
help them across the border but those
coyotes sometimes have ties to the drug
trade and rape and abuse are common in
the last decade thousands have been
found dead while attempting to cross the
border
if they do make it across they face an
entire apparatus of Customs and Border
Patrol the largest federal enforcement
agency in the nation it is equipped with
guns drones
towers ground sensors helicopters
gunboats and dogs to police the border
and what some consider militarization
rather than security look it's a border
surveillance blimp the budget for this
increased by 75% in the last decade to
13 and a half billion dollars a year
together with what the US spends on ice
that's more money than the DEA the FBI
and the Secret Service combined between
2004 and 2015 the number of border
agents more than doubled the CBP
operates in what the u.s. considers
border territory which is anything a
hundred miles from the border itself
here anyone can be stopped on reasonably
suspicious grounds even if they're a
citizen it's all part of a strategy to
stop border crossing through deterrence
the idea that the more people fear
crossing the less likely they are to do
it that might work if you don't mind
what it implies more danger more deaths
and a ripe market for human smuggling
but is it actually keeping America safer
despite Trump and other politicians
claims Isis isn't coming across the
southern border there has yet to be a
single apprehension of someone with
links to the Islamic state
the current wall covers just 653 miles
of the border and has already cost the
u.s. seven billion dollars five million
dollars per mile in some areas experts
estimate that to cover the entire border
with a wall would cost twenty five
billion dollars and that's not even
including labor there are logistical
hurdles to because of treaties the US
has signed with Mexico it can't build on
the Rio Grande floodplains and much of
the border in Texas is privately owned
and not everyone wants a giant wall in
their backyard so even with all the
money in the world and our very own
great wall of America can we ever stop
movement across the border by force and
will it make us safer